[Música]
me encantaría empezar con algún chiste o
algo simpático para aflojar las
tensiones de entrada pero me di cuenta
que la que tiene que aflojar tensiones
soy yo así que ahí vamos
mi nombre es iris y como en las
películas se coloca la frase toda
similitud con la realidad es pura
coincidencia bueno en mi relato toda
similitud con la realidad es pura verdad
siempre fui muy confiada creí que las
cosas se iban a solucionar acumular voy
a saber por qué obra de magia o mandato
ingenuos había instalado en mí desde la
niñez
fue la menor de cuatro hermanos y la
única opción que tenía de chica era
callar para soportar tanta autoridad de
parte de mi padre no lo culpo él no
podía dar algo que no tenía
no me siento no me considero víctima no
me siento así
me identifico mejor como sobreviviente
recuerdo las voces de mi mamá haciéndome
señas con el dedo acusado sólo su boca
quédate callada
no había que agregar más leña al fuego
ella soportó tantos silencios que fueron
silenciando su vida
falleció a los 49 años
ser sobreviviente no se elige
sobreviviendo se construye una vida como
se puede
pero como se hace para construirla
recuerdo las voces de mis chiquitos que
me decían mamá si vos estás bien
nosotros también
qué claras y simples palabras
pero qué difícil poder entenderlas
cuando no lo estás pasando bien
lo cierto es que una y otra vez me
chocaba con la misma piedra entender
porque no estaba bien
qué cosas me dejaban de estar bien
tan sutilmente empieza todo que casi ni
te das cuenta
crees que es amor
pero el amor no te deja un sabor amargo
ni vacío no te reprime el corazón no te
reprime tus emociones por miedo
vamos soportando
y esos silencios que estaban susurros
estaban en mi corazón no se va
silenciando esos que los veía en mi
madre los iba sintiendo en mí
creemos que es natural quedarnos
calladas y aceptar
que nos controlen el tiempo como
vestirnos que amistades tener como
maquillar tiene que color teñirte
nos adaptamos
quizás por miedo a perder todo lo que
construiste que no es mucho pero es todo
lo que tienes
a no tener nada para darle a tus hijos
cómo vas a ser para mantenerlos o la
mejor aguanta de los atómica está loca
seguirá aceptando
pero tu corazón que lo estaba marcando
algo no andaba bien
te sentís
a ver que te sentís que estás pero no
estás
que sos parte pero no formas parte
que tus sueños y proyectos se desvanecen
así no se logran encasillando los roles
y quitándonos la voz
te sentís invisible humillada y dejaste
en otras manos tu vida para que un otro
decida por vos
pensar que realmente estás equivocada
que puede ser este lugar
dejas de opinar
no contradijo para no provocar
y así se va tornando cada vez
más rojo el semáforo de la violencia
yo no pensaba que era violencia yo
pensaba que si no había golpe no había
violencia
pero hace falta el golpe para darse
cuenta que tu corazón se queda sin aire
late fuerte
te quedas totalmente sin aire
empiezas a sentir ese latido fuerte
cuando empiezan las peleas verbales el
manejo del dinero y en si seguís
poniendo la mirada en este otro para su
aprobación
te sentís
te sentí vacía
se va apagando tu mirada tu cuerpo
ya no escuchas a tu corazón late fuerte
solo para seguir sobreviviendo
seguís pensando
estás
pero no estás
tu corazón late
así no se logra encasillando nos des
quitándonos la voz
cuándo
escuchas de vuelta mamá si vos estás
bien nosotros también
ya la tiene en tu corazón
ya no podía seguir así
tantas idas y vueltas como voy a hacer
para denunciar a la persona que me ama
que me ama el maltrato psicológico una
autoestima destruida por el emmy latir
con furia basta
mamá si vos estás bien nosotros también
tomes de esas palabras la valentía mi
dolor como aliado y avance buscando las
salidas basta basta de soportar bastará
aguantar humillaciones basta de
naturalizar basta de moretones del
corazón basta
con una pala con una mirada lejana
a veces nos quedamos
en el vacío pese a que no podéis salir
solas por eso empezamos a buscar salida
mamá si vos está bien nosotros también
comer de esas palabras la valentía y
salí buscando las salidas
con una mirada lejana pero a veces tan
cerca también ves a otras mujeres
salir en los grupos de ayuda encontramos
esa empatía que nos fortalece guiada por
mujeres y profesionales admirables que
supieron conectar nuestras emociones en
palabras abrir puertas legales penales
que también son los hectáreas para
avanzar y sentirse fuerte el camino no
es fácil sentir que corres riesgos
a veces tienes ganas de tirar todo el
[ __ ] porque la justicia tiene otros
tiempos y te cansan no tienen tu misma
urgencia pero sabes que es el camino que
se que tenés que caminar y avanzar por
eso
cuándo
te sientas abatida
estás a buscar esta ayuda y encontrar
ya los moretones del corazón no están en
primer plano quedan las cicatrices
que te recuerda que peleaste para
encontrarte redescubrir de sentirte
entera y libre
hoy mamá si vos estás bien nosotros
también
cobra el verdadero significado
hoy me siento digo y vivo estar bien y
mis hijos también porque cuando una
mujer dice no es lo
porque hay un gigante que la fortalece
solo depende de tu decisión
que vamos a tener a seguir teniendo
miedos seguramente que si es natural
tenerlos lo que no es natural
lo que no es natural es que se nos
imponga el miedo como amenaza ni ser
parte de una estadística de horror una
muerte cada 30 horas ni tantas otras
muertes en vida por silencios que nos
figuran en las estadísticas tampoco
deberíamos tener la opción de ser
sobreviviente o ser víctima acá la única
opción es ser somos conscientes que
todavía seguimos naturalizando
situaciones en donde en que se casilla a
la mujer y nos colocan en desigualdad de
condiciones o será que es más cómodo
mirar para otro lado y no involucrarse
involucrarse
es no ser indiferente al otro ni a uno
mismo
por eso cuando te sientas abatida que ya
no te quedan fuerzas y te siguen
diciendo que estás loca no te rindas
busca ayuda
escuchar tu corazón escuchemos nuestro
corazón en este momento si lo acompañan
y ponemos la mano en el corazón por un
minuto un instante y sintamos este latir
escuchemos
nuestro latido
es una conexión que tenemos hoy que es
el mismo latir que tenemos del de al
lado el latir que tengo yo el latir que
tenemos
los vertidos no tienen género los
latidos son conectores de vida
por eso
mamá si vos estás bien hoy cobra
verdadero significado sé que esta es una
de tantas historias que vivimos las
mujeres en el día a día por generación
en generación sé también que hoy tenemos
muchas herramientas para poder
diferenciar el peligro y poder salir
antes
escucha tu corazón
su fortaleza empieza cuando separas todo
lo que te lastimas tomas tu verdad para
transformar el dolor
sí también
que hoy
si yo pude
todas podemos
todas tenemos las herramientas solo
depende de tu decisión
si también hoy
que cuando nos vayamos de acá
pensemos que tenemos todas las mujeres
tenemos las mismas herramientas pero no
todas pudieron salir
lamentablemente cuando cruzamos el río
luján hacemos del lado de la costa
veamos un mármol que la recuerda a ella
a carolina que con tan solo 16 años la
violencia de género le arrebató su vida
su corazón y a tantas otras víctimas que
nunca sabremos si pudieron escuchar su
corazón
y poder salir a tiempo del peligro hoy
sus corazones no están pero si su latir
en cada uno de nosotros para recordarlas
para tomar conciencia
y no olvidar tantos moretones del
corazón basta podemos parar la violencia
tomemos conciencia escucha tu corazón
gracias
o